oh my god go to Hell's Kitchen you'll
find plenty of colorful underwear but
how do I get to Hell's Kitchen from here
hello and welcome to the other show my
name is Chris Kelly and this is Sarah
and we're here to talk about episode 3
which is chase gets a girlfriend yes and
we have Drew and Hellena and Ken Marino
hello people somebody just clicked away
hey hey hey gay brother we have an
important PR opportunity to discuss it
was my idea yeah and it's for tonight so
we have no time to waste I thought it
right out the gate this is very cheesy
to say to your face but we were big fans
of yours for a while I mean since we
were like three or four we just listen
to some of the first words I said where
Ken Marino no but we have just loved you
and everything and we were so excited
when you were willing to take a coffee
to talk about the show we did have a
communication
we're on mute now so everybody keep
smiling don't move your list because
this is very bad am i doing it on my
lips moving I gotta get this pictures
gonna suck I got a when we met with you
you already kind of had like a lot of
ideas for this character I did you
pitched us immediately that he had to
empty jacuzzis at his home and a lazy
river that ran between them but he had
to run out of money to fill them so they
were just empty so the whole season he's
dealing with the permits never gets it
ultimately he wasted a lot of money on
it so in watching the show just know
that the character is street art we'd
never mentioned it but he is dealing
with a lot of permitting issues I can't
talk right now his neck is bound what
control got to keep that neck looking
young and sleek the character does a lot
of things that are a little rough to a
child like in the previous episode he's
binding his neck you know to get his
Adam's apple down bleaches his tongue
yeah he's
making it Pinker and so but we were
trying to find the balance of someone
who could sell that comedy without being
like holy I hope that works out I
guess we'll see is kind enough to hurt a
child we're talking in the room we
thought it was funny because the day
that chase dreams lands in New York he
immediately moves into Justin Thoreau's
penthouse and how ridiculous that is in
comparison to like how we probably all
lived when we moved there when we were
19 I moved to New York when I was 22
right after college and I saved up and
within 10 minutes of being there two
people walked up to me at gunpoint and
stole all of my things completely robbed
me stole all of my suitcases and so then
I called my dad and he was like we will
never tell your mother about this
because she was so terrified that I was
moving to New York so we just never told
my mom about it how many but I've been
mugged I was mugged you had that was
mugged in is everybody I was in college
I went away for Thanksgiving and came
back and my house had been emptied like
literally the washer and dryer was gone
it was like one inch what but they did
leave one DVD which had a message and
the DVD was you got served well that's
good well maybe I should have been
robbed I was trying to buy Dave Matthews
Band tickets and I was like okay I want
him because I have bad taste in music
and so I put him in my pocket and I
turned around and was walking away and I
looked down and it was for like two days
before it was like the wrong ticket I
ran after him and he hopped the
turnstile so I stood at the turnstile
and was like he's robbed to me and
everyone just looked at him and then got
out of his way did he even look back no
no no no what he left and I got wait is
this Justin throws apartment yes how did
you know because I'm looking at a huge
photo of him so I hope it is
I'm curious about how you pick the
Justin Theroux photo which is like this
um like something there's just like the
Panthers actually there were pubes but
then we had to take the pubes out take
the pubes down tamp down the pubes I'm
hoping that like when it airs on Comedy
Central there's no pubes but then if you
watch it on iTunes we I when I was in
college was flirting with a guy and
weirdly it was like a thing for girls to
like let guys know they were like
flexible I went to theaters yeah and I
was a dancer I did splits at so many
parties being like this is crazy I can
just fall into this I was a virgin I was
talking to a guy into that point tried
to do a high kick as you do in normal
conversation and I kicked so hard that I
kicked my other foot out from under me
and landed on my back in the middle of
the quad what it impressed him I've
definitely learned too many john mayer
songs on the guitar
oh let's and finish it well thank you
for watching
this has been another episode of the
other show and we'll see you next week
to a kick
[Music]
you